if you looked at the slide deck we have
a lot to cover today we have 285 slides
for one lecture it's uh it's going to be
some slides are going to be faster paced
than usual but uh I think we'll make it
work today we're going to look at
implicit models SL generative
adversarial
networks here's the outline of things
we're going to cover um some things in
more detail than others but uh for
everything you'll have the reference on
the slides so we'll start with some
motivation and a definition of implicit
models so this is a tweet from a few
years ago Ian Goodfellow the inventor of
Gans um tweeted this to showcase the
rapid progression in quality of
generation quality of samples generated
by Gan models started in 2014 just four
year four years later L by 2018 was much
higher resolution much higher quality
generation along this single line of
work um big Gan 2018 was one of the big
um big kind of coming of age moments for
Gans because it was Deep Mind training a
much larger Gan than had been trained
before and as a consequence the
generations were yet so much better than
they had been before and really
established Gans at the time as the uh
prevalent uh IM generation method in
fact I went back to the 2020 lecture and
in the 2020 lecture we say something
along the lines of all image generation
today is done with
ganss that was a correct statement in
2020 um all the other methods were kind
of you know promising and interesting
but were not used for image generation
now today most image generation has done
with diffusion models which we'll cover
next next week um but um Gans can also
generate really good images and we'll
look at that today and um in fact once
we look at diffusion models you'll see
that part of these diffusion models
actually use again under the hood um and
the Google's mobile diffusion that came
out just uh two weeks ago also uses a
gan to dramatically speed up the ability
to uh generate images so Gans are still
quite critical even they're not the you
know One-Stop shop for image generation
they are a pretty important component in
some of the best image gener ation
today
now this is one of the funny things that
happen with Gans
um of course at the bottom there is the
equation that is behind Gans that we'll
cover in detail soon it's also the
signature of this image um that was
generated by somebody who then sold it
at Christies for you know the first AI
visual art that was sold and they made a
good amount of money they did not invent
Gans they did not write the code to do
this um they did collect the data uh of
that style to then train in that style
that might you know be good to sell at a
traditional art auction house and they
succeeded so pretty
cool so so far in this course we've
covered autoaggressive models flow
models latent variable models all have
their strengths and weaknesses um all
three of those actually have a common
aspect they're likelihood based model
you're optimizing the log prop of your
data um today we're going to look at
something a little
different so what we like from a
generative model is ability to sample
evaluate the likelihood to train them
well and to have a good
representation um but with Gans kind of
the starting point even though we will
get some of the others as we progress
through the lecture the starting point
is what if all we care about is
generating good
samples and let's worry about the other
thing another time let's focus on
generating good
samples well the simplest solution of
high quality samples you just load in
your data set you randomly pick an image
from your data set and it's a high
quality sample of the same quality as
your data set um of course that's kind
of a noop that that doesn't really give
you a generative model that allows you
to create anything new but if all you
care about is high quality samples in
some sense this is enough so we got to
be careful we don't fall into this
corner case as we uh try to create a
good sample
so you don't just want to sample the
exact data points you already have um
you want to build a generative model
that can understand the underlying
distribution of data points and smoothly
interpret across the training samples
right I put samples similar but not the
same as the training data samples output
samples are representative of the
underlying factors of variation in
training distribution for example maybe
for some people you see them up front
another person you see from the side and
maybe maybe an interesting sample would
be the person which you only had an
image from the front now you get to see
from the side because that means the
model understands that things that
you've seen from the front could also
appear in principle looked upon from the
side um or maybe in digits um you have a
bunch of handwritten digits and maybe
one of the digits is always written with
a thin uh pen or something but the
others have variation in thickness so
maybe you understand that oh maybe this
other digit could also have a variation
in thickness and I can start generating
that so you'd hope that somehow the
sample generator understands the factors
underlying the generation and they can
generate different versions of uh what's
in your training
data so in implicit models the the ones
we're going to cover here we sample Z
from a fixed noise Source distribution
uniform or gaussian that should look
pretty familiar and then we pass a noise
through a deep neural network to obtain
a sample X um flow model Vees were set
up the exact same way what's going to be
different here is that we're going to
learn the Deep Neal Network without
explicit density estimation so we're not
going to try to find a NE Network that
maximizes the probability of the
training data we're going to do things a
little
different
so in an implicit model given our data
distribution um and in fact not the data
distribution given samples from our data
distribution X1 through xn we try to uh
build a sampler let's call it qf which
turns Z into a sample where Z comes from
some prior that's easy to sample from
and then this qz will introduce a
density um which is density of our model
in
xace um we're not going to make the
assumption that we can evaluate P model
in any way with flow models we're able
to evaluate it with VES we're able to
evaluate it aggressive we're able to
evaluate that here we're now making that
assumption it can be any Neal Network
that turns a noise essentially Vector Z
into maybe an images images is what
we're trying to generate or maybe speech
maybe text and so forth um so we not
have an explicit form for this for these
U distributions but we still want
somehow them to be close that's our goal
and so as you can imagine we somehow
have to find a way to by looking at the
samples that are
generated tweak the Q5 such that the
samples look like they could have come
from the data distribution because that
would mean the two distributions have
gotten
close so we have to measure that the
distance between P data and P model even
though we don't have an explicit P model
so we can't just look at this directly
because it's just not available to
us so the original Gan by Ian Goodfellow
and collaborators actually the backstory
even though we're short in time I got to
tell the backstory Ian invented Gans in
a bar he was working on other
unsurprised learning techniques and they
were just generating all these like
fuzzy images and it occurred him wait
even a new network can realize that this
image is fuzzy and not look like what is
in the data the trending data
distribution so why can't I just use
that n network as a feedback mechanism
to then train my generator to generate
images that look more
realistic um so that's a high level idea
this is Ian um he did this work while he
was a student at Montreal um from there
he went to Google then went to open eye
for a bit went back to Google um this G
paper has a lot of citations I just
grabbed that a couple days ago the
screenshot from Google Scholar if you
had written that paper just that paper
alone would have gotten you over 70,000
citations it's hard to get to 70,000
with all your papers combined we write
the correct paper um you can get it done
in with one paper you know just one
paper is
enough um now part of this is that it's
so successful part of this as you'll see
through the lecture is that actually
Gans are not so easy to get to work so
there's a lot of followup work coming up
with ideas of how to make it actually
succeed even better and better um
because just out of the box it's it's
not all the way there so yeah I guess
the key idea is you write a paper that
is the first in its category was a lot
of room for improvement with the right
idea for many people to build upon and
to Tender a molecule add to that either
you write that paper or you write the
final paper on the topic so everybody
can decide that this problem been solved
those are the two ways you write the
first or the last paper on on a topic
that's that's the best strategy it's not
easy to do I guess the best lofty goal
to
have so this is the equation that's
going to matter for this lecture we'll
see variations on this but this this is
the foundation of what a gan model is
we're going to train two neural networks
a network D and network g g stands for a
generator a network that generates
images let's say to make it Concrete in
this class will essentially all be
images and d stands for discriminator
discriminator takes in an image and
discriminates whether it's an image
generated by the generator than well an
image that came from the training data
so let's first look at the discriminator
objective the discriminator is trying to
maximize there's two terms the first
term says expect expected value Sally
when I sample from my data my training
data log probability under the
discriminator so I want this to be a
high probability so my discriminator
think of it as some N Net that at the
end outputs a sigmoid effectively a
probability between Z and one saying How
likely it is that this sample was coming
from the training data and so I going to
try to put a one on this on the output
whenever it's from the training data
which will maximize this log because if
it's a probability coming off
discriminator 0 to one is the range you
have so try to you know this this will
strive to one
on data from our training
distribution and then on the other end
here the
discriminator is acting on generated
samples and again the whole thing is
being maximized but there's a flipped
sign here so actually here it's trying
to drive things to zero and it's trying
to understand that that is a generated
sample so a good discriminator will
assign a zero probability on the output
to a generated sample and a one
probability of being real on a training
data uh
sample so that's a discriminator job is
just training a standard classifier so
there's nothing else going on just a
standard image classifier with two
labels that's it real or fake um zero
essentially is the fake detector and one
is for
Real okay that's a discriminator and as
you see in the pseudo code that's all it
does you just train a classifier that's
all there is to it how about the
generator the generator only
participates over
here what does it do it's trying to
minimize this OB Ive um okay what does
that mean it's essentially working
against the discriminator it's the
simplest way to think of it the
discriminator is trying to drive this
down to zero because that'll that'll
satisfy its objective as well as
possible but the generator has the
flipped objective so it's actually
trying to drive the generator is trying
to drive this to one not its own output
but the imagees it generates it wants
the discriminator to think they are real
and the better it does that the closer
will drive this thing up to one as a as
a discriminator will not be able to
distinguish from the real images and
that way um it'll optimize its objective
and so a way to think of is that
essentially what you have here is you
have and when you train a generator the
generator generates image gets fed into
a scoring system which happens to be
called a discriminator and then you try
to maximize your score discriminator
tries to work against you but once the
discriminator is fixed you've already
trained a discriminator let's say the
gener is just trying to get scored as
well as possible make things as real as
possible now you can imagine this is a
game theoretic setting so once the
discriminator is fixed and it generator
start generating things at some point
the discriminator might want to change
their mind and say like it looks like
generator generates things like this and
you need to Trend these both in some
kind of synchronization to make this
work out um so there's some
complications here and you know at some
point maybe this discriminator is doing
better sometimes generator is doing
better and so forth
now at the equilibrium because that's
one way to think of what you're going
for here when you have a mmax objective
you try to maybe achieve the equilibrium
at the equilibrium um what happens is
the generator will generate images that
are
indistinguishable from the real data and
the discriminator the best thing it can
do when everything is 50/50 it can't
decide is to also outut a 50/50 on its
output so that is the equilibrium of
this particular formulation
discriminator ends up at 50/50 generator
generates exactly what is
indistinguishable from training
data now you might say indistinguishable
from training data you know aren't you
then generating exact copies and so
forth that's in some sense where some
choices come in right this discriminator
will not be something that can memorize
the training data you don't want it to
be able to memorize a train you want it
to be a newal network with you know
weights that are in some sense capturing
the essence of the training data but
don't literally memorize the training
data and that's how you end up with
success really is that from the
Viewpoint of the discriminator it can't
distinguish between real and fake and
another way to think of is that the way
a designer discriminator determines you
know what that equilibrium could look
like that you end up at if you design
discriminator as just a memorizer then
you just end up with repeating the
training data for the generator but
that's not what you want but if you do
something more regularized in your
discriminator end up with something much
better any questions about this
equation okay let's see what we can do
um so this is what it looks like um in
some sense pictorially as you're
training here you're training you know
you have the generator is here and then
discriminator is here and here
um and since you have two pipelines you
have the fake data pipeline this is
real this is fake Pipeline and both go
through this pipeline both hit the
discriminator but the fake only
interacts uh or or gets generated by the
generator pseudo code okay you sample
some noise you then
um generate some data with the generator
from that noise and then you update the
discriminator to be maximally good at
classifying distinguishing between fake
and real then for your generator you
again uh sample some noise you feed it
into the generator objective do back
propagation and update the weights such
that what you generate from that noise
is according to the current
discriminator considered more realistic
than it was before so that in some sense
it looks simple but in practice that
game theoretic equilibrium can be pretty
hard to achieve and that's where a lot
of the uh challenges come
in
um shall we do this the internet
collection internet connection seem
pretty bad in here let's see what it is
doing yeah I don't think we have good
enough connection to
to look at this demo so you can do that
um at home if you want but essentially
it visualizes in 2D how the training of
a gan can proceed discriminator and
Generator evolving over time decision
boundary for discriminator and where the
samples are generated by the generator
um shifting over time at convergence in
simple examples what you'll see is that
the generator will drop the points in
that 2D space roughly in the region
where the training data is also situated
these are some samples from 2014 10
years ago um amness
digits um
faces um I think this bottom left is C
far and this might also be C or maybe
some kind of heavily down sampled other
thing of image net um so this was at the
time very promising looking right now
this doesn't look super sharp um you're
like okay well that's that's not a great
result
compared to state of your today but at
the time this was looking much better
than anything before and you'll soon get
some intuition as to
why now how to evaluate evaluation for
Gans is still an open problem actually
um and part of it is if you just look at
the objective right remember how I
described the objective at the
equilibrium you have this weird state
where the discriminator is like
50/50 and you're supposed to generate
things that look like a training data
but what does it even mean like there's
not a lik like score that tells you how
well you're doing is just an equilibrium
so you don't get a score out the way
these other models have great log prop
scores to to understand how well they're
doing so what are some alternatives to
evaluate aside from eyeballing the
results in the early days when things
were still done in lower dimensional
spaces um because there was less compute
um people often looked at kernel density
estimators as a substitute for um
likelihood what do you do there
essentially a kernel density estimator
says if I have some samples for example
in 1D I have a SLE here here and here
you blob a gaussian around it and you
then say my distribution is the average
of these
gaussians that's what this thing does um
so if all you can do is generate samples
you can say I'm just going to generate a
bunch of samples and then drop gaussians
around them and that's my density and
now I can evaluate the log
probability of my training data or even
maybe my validation data under that
density that my samples are creating and
so this way you after training again you
have a sample generator you use a sample
generator take the samples Gan blobs
around it and then you can go evaluate
the log prop of your original
data um the width of the window you take
can very much influence what you end up
with a wider window would make it
smoother a narrow window would make it
more bumpy um in one day it's pretty
easy to eyeball what the right width is
to get a clean result in higher
Dimensions you're probably going to have
a harder time um doing that but you
could maybe run a cross validation over
different widths you could say I take a
range of uh standard deviations I try
all of them and see which one does the
best and then just run with that as what
I supposedly have as my
density um at the time adversarial Nets
were actually doing
quite well um compared to some of the
other stateof art models at the time so
in low Dimensions this was actually
giving some decent
scores later as people started digging a
bit deeper just a year later um start
realizing that the problem is that as
you keep sampling um it seems that you
somehow don't really fill the space this
is a case where they know what the
ground truth L lik should be if you
perfectly train something and they see
that they keep sampling from their train
gam they never get close to it they keep
very far away from it so putting these
gausian bumps around your training data
is not getting a job done now one way we
already know this from a previous
lecture is that if you put a gausian
bump around an image in image space in
pixel space you put probability Mass on
a lot of things that are completely
unrealistic so you can never get a super
high log prob because you're spreading
your probability too thin across things
that are unrealistic just by definition
of putting that gussan around the things
you
generated so people came up with
something else called Inception score
this happened another year later um so
the idea was good generators generate
samples that are semantically
diverse um because that was a big part
of the problem Gans would because of the
discriminator forcing function would
generate realistic looking images but
sometimes they would be very similar to
each other the diversity would be too
limited so that means you're not
covering the data distribution you're
just covering a few data points
effectively that you're very similar to
and so a good way to then evaluate
whether your Gan has done well in terms
of capturing the diversity in the data
is to look at um essentially and this
when people were training on imag net um
look at the classification
labels right so you train your Gan you
generate samples and then you run an
image net classifier and in this case
there was an imet classifier called
Inception which is a specific imet
classifier Network use the Inception
Network to classify the generated
samples and if the generated
samples get correctly classified that
would be great but now you have to go in
and inspect so that's that's not ideal
so as a substitute what people said to
make this automatic let's just see if
the classifier is confident about what
class each sample is from and so if each
sample that was generated is confidently
classified as one of the Thousand imag
net classifications then it means that
the Gan is generating images that are
not some weird interpolation between
different classes which you want to
avoid but actually generating clear uh
images belong to clear categories
moreover if a category is missing it'll
also give you a bad Inception score you
can have some category completely
missing that drops your score so what
this ensures is that you have coverage
across all classes at least assuming the
Inception classifier is reasonably
accurate you then it means you have
coverage across all classes and um when
you are in a class you're confident
about it mean that you had a really good
representative of that class that you
generated okay there's some little
derivation here given we have 285 slides
to cover I'm let you go through that
derivation yourself but you got the main
idea and so what people would then do is
they would also iall it they would say
let's eyeball and also look at the
Inception score and see if the Inception
core Inception score improvements align
with our eyeballing happier being
happier about some uh certain Gans that
we trained and so one thing you can
actually also do is you look at real
data real data has an exception score of
11.24 um our methods this is again paper
at the time 8.09 so not exactly where
the real data is so this means there's
likely still a good amount of room for
improvement on the Gan that was was
trained in that paper but it's doing
better than some previous uh unsurprised
learning methods for image image
generation that were stateof the art at
that
time now one thing
um that you can do you can say hey
actually if you if you literally
optimize for the Inception score there's
still a bug in it meaning that in
principle you can generate
just a single image of each class so
there's a thousand different images and
you generate just those thousand images
and nothing else one of each class these
will be sharp they will belong clearly
to a class and so you have a great
Inception score but you don't have any
within class diversity which you also
want so the frese Inception distance
adds that to the evaluation which says
you also going to look at essentially
the mean and cence of the features in a
certain layer so the Inception Network
you'll process instead of just looking
at the classification at some
interesting layer you'll say let's look
at the features the Fe activations in
that layer and compute the first and
second order statistics in that layer
and compare that between real data and
the generated data and if the first and
secondary statistics match closely then
likely we are doing better and
eyeballing wise comparing that with this
score indeed this score seems to reflect
that you do better when you have a
better score here this is a distance
metric actually so you want to be be
lower to do
better um to Showcase this um this is a
2017 paper um this is the Fret in
Inception distance so this is the one we
just talked about that also looks at
these statistics uh inside the Inception
classifier
Network you can see as we put more
perturbation going left to right put
more perturbation on images
the FID goes up which means it gets
worse so indeed worse images or a pool
of worse images will get a worse score
than a pool of better images which is
what we'd be hoping
for in contrast the original Inception
distance kind of stays flat or bumps up
and back down so it doesn't really
capture this um the way we would want to
so think of the FID is essentially a
higher dimensional way of capturing what
quality of data you're generating what
diversity of data you're generating and
hence being more precise also a bit more
expensive to
evaluate okay so what are the key pieces
of again fast sampling right that
Network could be anything there's no
constraints doesn't have to be a flow no
no particular property it's just a
network that goes from noise to
hopefully realistic images with the
right setting of The
parameters optimize directly for what
you care about perceptual quality of the
samples right that's the direct
optimization objective does it look
perceptually similar to my training data
uh we have no inference that is we
cannot evaluate these probabilities yes
I talked about this kind of you know
pars and window gausian blobs approach
to still do that in low Dimensions but
once you go to High Dimensions which
what what we usually care about there is
there is no such thing
available was there a question there is
act reason why we use Inception or just
like is there a reason why we used the
Inception Network it was the kind of
state-of your art Network at that time
so it was the natural one to use at that
time
and people kept using it because the
comparison stay consistent that way um
there are better classifiers now you
could argue maybe we should use a new
classifier but how are you going to
compare your numbers with the numbers
from before you'd have to effectively
rerun all the old stuff to then see
where you land
um so um I guess it was a good enough
Network that people haven't had the
motivation to say we need to use a more
know upto-date Network for this
particular
purpose yes how do you that the produces
fores yeah how do we ensure the
generator produce image for all thousand
classes um the evaluation metrics check
for that but of course we don't directly
optimize against them um we will talk
about that a bit later in class that is
actually one of the big challenges with
Gans and there's a bunch of tricks that
tried to make sure that that happens
none of them we have talked about so far
but it's the it's the exact thing that
essentially motivated people to look at
um diffusion models as an alternative to
Gans and then kind of took off from
there
yes
yeah it's it's a good question if you
put the a valuation scores into the
objective of Gan would it improve it
would definitely improve on that
objective I don't know if it would
improve the generation quality that's
not
super obvious whether it would
um I will say there are some things
related to it that if people have put
into training mechanisms and we'll look
at them later um but never exactly that
maybe because they want to have a chance
to still have a clean evaluation but
definitely related things have been
included yes what makes sure that in the
lat space things are Clos
together yeah how how do we ensure that
the latent space is Meaningful that
nearby things uh have similar renderings
effectively
um as phrased so so far it's essentially
just the fact that the generator network
is a neural network and hence you know
the way it processes things nearby
things are more likely going to end up
nearby than far away things but there's
not a whole lot of pressure on that in
the current formulation there will more
pressure on that in some later
formulations great great questions yeah
last one so like in the previous lect so
like with the auto encoder for example
you could like interpolate through the
distribution that you were learning but
because you don't have an exposive
distribution anymore you can't do things
like that anymore right so can you still
interpolate um so two parts to this one
is if you're generating samples you
could still interpolate between the Z's
and then generate things in between and
it'll actually be pretty
meaningful now if you had real images
you don't have disease
because there is no encoder Network at
least not as formulated so far it'll
come later there are versions that have
an encoder network but as formulated so
far there's no encoder Network so
there's no way to interpolate between
the real images just
yet great so let's look at a little bit
of theory that might help motivate what
we just covered uh from a few additional
angles so the discriminator is supposed
to decide between the two classification
labels real versus
generated
um now imagine just a 1D situation where
we have a model generator distribution
that's shown in green and then a data
distribution shown with the dots and
they're pretty close um because maybe
the data we're generating is starting to
get pretty close to our um our training
distribution
now what would a discriminator look like
an optimal discriminator once there is
overlap in the distributions it's not
going to be zero in some places one in
other place is going to have a gradual
transition the base optimal thing to say
when you look at that log probability
objective if you're trying to maximize
the log probability score of your
discriminator if the discriminator is
uncertain it's actually incurs to Output
exactly it's the pro the correct
probabilities so for example
over over here it's pretty much
guaranteed to be one class so it's going
to be close to one but then once both
classes have probability is kind of
gradually shifting from one to zero and
that's the optimal thing for the
discriminator to do that's just the way
the objective is set up it's
incentivized to Output the precise log
probabilities of each class because for
example if you landed over here and we
go up then looks like the green is about
twice as high as the blue so then you'd
want to output something like 1/3 for
one class and 2/3 for the other
class that's the right thing to Output
okay so we can actually revisit our game
theoretic formulation for Gan and um try
to solve it since we know what the
optimal discriminator should output we
can actually in closed form effectively
try to solve for this um this of course
assumes that discriminator is not bound
to be a neural net because then we have
to do it through the weights which is
harder but just as a thought exercise if
the discriminator was not bound to use
weights in a neur net to make his
decisions but it's just open end that
can do whatever it once full open-ended
possibility what would it do at the
optimum um discriminator acts on gz and
on X we're going to write the gz that
generated um samples as just x uh we
integrate over the entire space of X and
then there's a waiting by the
probability of that one being generated
no we don't have this PGX available but
we're just doing a theoretical exercise
here and so now we get an objective of
the type shown here there's a
probability under the data of this
particular X Times log discriminator X
and then probability under the generator
of that x * log 1us DX if you
this is essentially equation of this
type a log y + B * log 1us y you
optimize this for y so the gr or the
derivative equal to zero you get y star
equals this and so we can do the same
thing over here with the original
notation and we find that the optimal
discriminator is this so if we knew P
data and we new P generation PG we could
write out the discrimin at this way that
is where it's trying to
go we'll continue with our thought
exercise and we fill it in so this is
our objective why don't we fill it
in into our objective the optimal form
that's why the star is here that denotes
the optimal discriminator we don't have
that available but we can think about
what would happen if we happen to get to
it um we fill it in and we can look at
this here and what it's really saying is
that the
objective the generator is optimizing
for assuming the discriminator always
jumps immediately let's say you're
generator discriminator game and we say
the discriminator always immediately
jumps to the optimal thing relative to
your data and your current generator
status then what is a generator doing
the generator is optimizing this
objective here which is a KL two kls one
from the data to the average of data and
generated the other one from generated
to the average of data and generated now
remember in our likelihood based models
that we covered so far it would have
been KL
P
data PG in the notation we're using here
that's not in there it's different um
but it has some similarities and this
could give you some comfort that maybe
the equilibrium we're striving for is a
pretty good equilibrium because we are
getting something where the
k um ideally these distributions
coincide at the equilibrium and that's
indeed what this would do if we fully
optimize it we'd get the generator to
make sure that that both of those K's
are
zero okay so that's nice now let's look
at what these K's really mean so we have
we can have K data to G we could have a
flipped version sorry about that we
could have a flipped
version
from G to
data and then we could have this one on
top here that is this mixed version it
goes in both directions but it's not
just average of both directions because
on the other side of the bar there's an
average ALS it's like averaging in two
places taking K in both directions and
averaging the thing that's behind the
double
bar let's take a look at what that means
in terms of a simple example if you're
doing
the regular K that we have tended to do
with our generative models so far
maximizing the log prop that corresponds
to this scale over here let's say the
underlying distribution is the blue
curve which has two bumps and you're
trying to fit it with the green curve
which is one gausian bump what will
happen is that um you will try to get
put some probability everywhere and why
is that because if anywhere there's a
data point from
P that has zero probability under Q you
hit negative Infinity in this objective
so Q has to have nonzero probability
everywhere where P has anything non zero
otherwise you're in
trouble if you flip
it
um what happens then since Q is what
we're
choosing and P is fixed p is the data
you effectively get the opposite effect
you try to position your Q wherever the
probability under p is the highest and
if you let it degenerate it'll actually
just become one super tall narrow Peak
right where your p is the highest that's
what would happen so this is called mode
seeking behavior and this is mode
covering now
what we have here is in some sense an
average of the two things in action and
gives you something in
between now the reason I said earlier
you might soon get some intuition as to
why Gan generated examples were more
crisp definitely compared to the models
at that time well the models at that
time were of this type and what you see
here is that your Q when you have a you
know the regular k your mode your Q is
trying to be everywhere needs to avoid
zeros and so what happens is that
anywhere between two samples you're
putting probability and unless you have
an amazing amazing neural network that
understands fully how things should be
embedded and so forth you're going to
put a lot of probability on things that
are not sharp because most things in
between samples are essentially like
Blurry average versions of these samples
and so if you do something mode covering
unless you have a really expressive
Network that's trained extremely
extremely move well you're going to end
up with blurry samples
effectively here when you're mode
seeking you do the opposite you try to
be very sharp but the problem is that
you just try to replicate one training
example and you're done so we don't want
that we want something in between and
that's in some sense what Gans are
giving us and so that's why they tend to
produce um sharper samples than the
models we've seen so far at least
definitely in the um smaller neural
network
regime so trade-offs for compression you
want to make sure everything is covered
so you need the regular kale that's mode
covering for good
samples that would lead to blurring we
just talked about that so um you also
don't want to pick one mode that's too
extreme so we need something um
something in between which effectively
Gans are
providing now question earlier how do
you ensure that it then still doesn't
collapse CU this game theoretic if the
discriminator says um let's say this
looks like a real one and that looks
like a fake why doesn't the generator go
generate everything where the
discriminator thinks it's real and just
focuses over there and that's actually
what happens if you train naively if
this is your target distribution you
train naively with no precautions you'll
essentially hop around between these
different modes you'll be generating a
certain mode and then at some point the
discriminator realizes yeah I know real
data is here too but it's only 10% of
the real data so I'm going to put only a
10% probability on it being real and 90%
on it being fake and then your generator
is like oh my God it's it's found me out
I got to hop to a different mode where
it's where it thinks it's real right now
and then the generator is ahead for a
little bit discriminator catches up and
it keeps going back and forth so that's
one of the big challenges in training
these at least in their original
formulations that's one of the
challenges there's another challenge um
we talked about this discriminator this
base optimal discriminator that says you
know this is exactly what at convergence
if generator is fixed what will I become
if I keep optimizing myself should we do
that should we let's say do one
generator step and then many many
discriminator steps and then again one
generator step is that a good idea or
not in the pseudo code definitely that
wasn't done it was discriminator steps
Follow by generator steps and hop back
and forth between two so I might give
you a that probably don't want to do
this um why
not
um once you train a discriminator
extensively too much in some sense for
this to work um what happens is it's
going to have a01 output everywhere once
there's a 01 output everywhere as you
use it discriminator as the signal to
tell you how to improve your generator
it's just saying no matter what you do
in this region it's all fake and so this
generator gets no signal anymore about
in which direction to push its weights
to get a more realistic looking image
all the signal has gone um so um this is
pictorially showing essentially if you
have sigmoids the sigmoids will saturate
and so then the derivative of the
sigmoid which is what you care about
will be zero which is uh
problematic and same will be true for
the
um reverse uh the the other side of the
classification so one thing you can do
is do a careful alternating optimization
make sure a discriminator does not
become too confident and so you can have
a lot of hyper parameters there to worry
about step sizes number of steps and so
forth batch sizes to make this work um
so you can imagine it's not an easy
thing to do but you know it's part of
what you do we have to
alternate another thing people do and it
might feel like a hack um is Essen just
change the objective um you don't like
that the sigmoid saturates just get rid
of that saturation where you don't like
it so the original Gan objective for the
generate generator has this log 1 minus
D um which is problematic when the
discriminator becomes uh close to
effectively in this case it would be
zero all the time saying it's always
fake you replace that with with just log
D um instead so this
part has become this here it's a flipped
sign here but also the the the Max and
the Min are flipped turns out once you
do that um you get nice nonzero
derivatives even when the discriminator
is very confident that you are a uh a
fake and so that's that's St fairly
standardly used instead of the original
objective now you might say well that's
interesting you had this beautiful game
thetic formulation min max and now it's
a it used to be a non it used to be a
zero sum game and now it's just nonzero
sum game where they're not directly
working against each other but
intuitively they're working against each
other still because the generator is
still trying to fool the discriminator
so conceptually it's still doing the
same thing but it's not a pure um Zero
Sum game
anymore but that's that's how it has
been done um then now what I want to do
is Step through a bunch of
the kind of Novelties that were
introduced after the original paper that
as you add this progression all up
essentially ends up with um the
extremely good generation that we
started achieving around 2018 that made
most people think this is this is all
done it's it's going to be all Gans from
here onwards now we know that didn't end
up being true but the generations are
very high quality it's not that the
quality isn't there um it's just
training is still a little bit harder
often and um making sure you Ash have
good coverage remains harder than it is
with the fusion models but who knows
they might make a full comeback at some
point so the first time Gan started
showing signs of like this is actually
working was a paper by Alec Ratford and
collaborators Alec Ratford by the way
also the person who originated the GPT
models out open ey the first few
generations of them um but before he was
at open ey he was doing some independent
research um in a small startup he had
started um and as part of that he uh he
wrote this paper which then we read out
open eye at the time and we said okay we
need to recruit this person because you
know that was essenti how we recruited
at the time we just see whatever cool
stuff comes on archive be like okay this
is a cool paper in archive one of the
coolest thing in a while let's make sure
we recruit Alec to to open
AI um so um what is what did it do um it
was starting to put some real thought
into how to set up the neural network
architecture to make this work so you
have a code going in then you have
deconvolutions going out um so it's a
upsampling effectively from a 100
dimensional code into something that's
the size of an image but it's a learned
upsampling that makes it look like an
image this is the generator here right
this is only the generator and this is
optimizing how well it can fool the
discriminator then there were a lot of
tricks that had to be done which I think
the big takeaway here is that sometimes
these tricks matter and I'll step
through them but also that it's not
great when you need to do this many
tricks to get something working because
then one mistake somewhere can throw it
off of course um
no no Max or mean pooling um which was
common at the time
um up sample with using transposed
convolutions which was on on the slide
which is a specific Choice down sample
for the discriminator with strided
convolutions um and average
pooling um Rue for the generator leak
your value for the discriminator this
thing can make sense right because you
know that you want the discriminator
signal to come back to your generator
and a leaky value will have more signal
propagation than regular values through
the network um 10age for the generator
because you want things between negative
1 and plus one normalized pixel values
sigmoid for the discriminator so that's
still the same um batch Norm to prevent
mode collapse so that that helps
introduce more variation um but it's
also weird because you'll see that
samples coming from the same batch will
have a weird correlation between them
because the batch no makes them
interact um not applied at the output of
generator and input of discriminator
relieve that a little bit and then a
bunch of optimization details this batch
size at the time by the way was large so
the way to think of this is that it was
observed in this paper that a larger
batch size can help you todaya that's
small but it's just the trend is larger
is better was um signaled
there um yeah I'll I'll skip over to um
key results there was an bedrooms data
set also Elson faces data set on which
the results started looking very very
good these are images of bedrooms that
look like they could be real bedrooms
you can recognize a bed a window a door
a dresser and so forth in various of
these
images same for faces both of these
results were just like Leaps and Bounds
beyond anything that anybody had done
with any generative model at that
time um you can you can interplate with
them as we talked about this is for the
generated images where you have access
to your Z you can interpolate get
meaningful interpolations so there's not
a whole lot of pressure in it being
meaningful but it does turn out
meaningful thanks to the architecture of
the neural network um image net samples
32x 32 that was something people weren't
even thinking of at the time that you
could maybe create imag net samples even
down sample to this resolution was kind
of thought of as wow this is really
surprising this is
possible you could do Indian space
arithmetic we talked about this at some
point with flow models in this case you
start with a smiling woman then you
subtract a neutral woman add a neutral
man so you change the gender and what
you end up with is a smiling man um so
this was a clear indication that these
things were starting to work um at the
time the interpolations and these
additions were done in the ukian space
of the embedding space since then people
have switched to keeping everything
normalized work on the circular Arc um
of the normalized space that giv
slightly better results but again this
was a big surprising result at the time
here's another one um men with glasses
men without glasses women without
glasses you combine that to give the
women glasses and here you are here's a
comparison by the way if you do this in
pixel space so this is interpolation in
pixel space which clearly is not looking
very realistic and so what we're seeing
here is that the new networks are learn
something about image structure and able
to reflect that in their
Generations um you could um yeah this
more more interpolation in this case um
seen some examples they looked at
classification on top so what you can do
is you can take your discriminator and
then add an extra layer to it and make
it a classifier for any kind of
classification problem you care about it
was trained to classify fake versus real
but it turns out by paying attention to
just that it's pre-trained very well to
also learn to classify into other
classes um so incredible samples for any
generative model at the
time at this point people knew Gans can
be made to work well with the right
architecture and training
details uh not only good samples Al also
good interpolations and the
representation is working which you can
see from the uh interpolations but also
from the classifier Train on top
problems still unstable training you
could training you could have just
terrible results nothing worked you have
no learning curve that tells you what
you're doing good or bad because it's
this game theoretic thing proba it seees
that the discriminator is winning
generator is losing and that's it and
but there's no natural like learning
curve
progression um and very brittle if you
change any of the hyperparameters
architecture things might stop
working so what happened next um
improved training of Gans um in fact
also involves Alec um led by Sim Tim
salomons at the time at open
AI um and
introduced five new ideas to make this
all work
better I'll STI through all five of
them first one is mini batch
discrimination this is a very natural
idea um but hadn't been done at the time
the idea is that if you have a batch of
samples and your discriminator is
looking at that batch of
samples and they all look similar
because you're starting to get mode
collapse the generator trar to generate
realistic things but they look all very
similar discriminator should just say
hey they all look the same this must be
generated because my data distribution
is more diverse and so instead of
discriminator acting on just one sample
at a time it gets to act on a batch of
samples to make it
decisions um there is already batch Norm
so in some sense discriminator was
already seeing old samples in some kind
of weird ined way but this is making it
more explicit essentially it's
introducing um uh an additional feature
Vector for each sample every step along
the way as the network is proc
processing it to look at how different
is this sample from all the others in
the feature space that we're currently
in in my discriminator layer and so that
helps in terms of stabilizing the train
because now you don't jump from mode to
mode because the discriminator
understands whether you're mode covering
or not and when you're not mode covering
you just get a single that you should be
better at mode
covering then um the
generator and this goes back to the
question what if you directly optimize
for this fret
Inception uh distance like the
statistics and feature space um it's not
doing exactly that it's not looking at
the Inception Network statistics but is
looking at the in this case um features
somewhere in the um discriminator and
it's saying somewhere in my
discriminator my statistics of my
features between real and fake data
should be similar so around than just
having a classification which is in some
sense onedimensional scaler output you
have a higher dimensional comparison
happening earlier on in your
discriminator so this gives it's an
additional loss giving an additional
signal for how to fix your
generator then um as it's done with
almost all of these Minimax games you
introduce some historical averaging so
even if you have a simple game like this
minimize over X maximize over y x *
y um when when you do this um you'll see
that if you do it naively essentially go
around in in circles um because one
choice of X leads to another choice of Y
being the right choice and it keeps
circling around so what do people do is
they say I need to choose my y against
my historical choices of x if it's good
against all past choices of X then it's
a better choice of Y and then X cannot
come up with a new solution all of a
sudden that gets me somehow and so the
same thing's Happening Here the Theta
that you end up using um ends up being
an average of all the past settings of
your
parameters um making the training a lot
more stable a more extreme version of
this would be to keep many
discriminators around and optimize your
generator in some decaying way against
many discriminators um that's of course
a lot more effort to keep many networks
around a lot more storage required this
is in some sense a approximation to
keeping all the uh past um incarnations
around
then this is what would happen within a
b batch uh with regular batch Norm um
which means very correlated samples um
instead they introduced virtual batch
Norm which is you based on prior data
you compute the mean and standard
deviation that would appear in each
layer for your features and now the
simplest thing we just use that but
that's not ideal because you're not
adjusting for your current batch so it's
actually using a half half mix of
whatever the mean and varans are from
your current batch and mean in variance
from where you pre-computed this
stabilizes it yet keeps um some
adaptation to your current
batch another thing that did is to I
think of this as weakening the
discriminator on um the cross entropy
loss um you set it as a Target 0.9
instead of one so you just do log
maximize the log prop you try to get to
one but instead set up a cross entropy
loss that makes you target
0.9 that way way you don't reach that
saturating part of the sigmoid of your
discriminator you just say that you
can't get there you're supposed to stay
in the regime where it's still uh has
more curvature to
it by the way this is only done on the
data um it's a little subtle but the
reason it's only done on the data is
um essentially the idea being that if
your samples are perfect your
discriminator doesn't need to get you
single signal anymore you're done so
it's less important um but you probably
do it on your samples too if if you
wanted
to then another thing that was done um
is that um your discriminator if you
have supervised data anyway it's meant
to be unsupervised learning but all of
these data sets at least in the early
days were all supervised data sets that
were repurposed for un supervised
learning so you're like well we know
this is image we know this is cfar we
know there are labels ass associated
with it what happens if we
actually force a discriminate to also
classify what class something belonged
to and turns out if you also do that
your discriminator gives more signal to
your generator to learn
better
um now that kind of goes back to
the Inception loss where you are asking
for a good classification and so in some
sense this is getting pretty close to
directly optimizing for that um to their
credit this paper actually in introduced
the Inception score so it's not like
they saw somebody else's score and then
um said let's optimize it and beat them
to it it was the paper that introduced
the Inception score as a way to evaluate
Gans um but yeah their objective in some
sense a little bit also optimizes for
it these are the samples now um and you
know low resolution are pretty good but
a high resolution it's still not so
great I mean there are some dog like
features on the right um but they're not
you know they don't look like regular
dogs let's put it that
way um actually this I was going to skip
then let's let's keep going because we
got a lot to cover um we're going to
transition now to W again which is going
to be a slight reformulation of the
objective that is um actually the most
used since since that came
out so we've seen that effectively with
Gans we're doing this um Jensen Shannon
Divergence optimization find a
distribution that is minimizing that J
jsd um these other measures you can have
of how far probability distributions are
away from each other so one thing about
the K Divergence is is something funny
about it same for reverse and ch D is if
I had a
distribution that looks let's
say like
this let's just make
it let's see actually let's make it
continuous because a lot of things we're
doing are continuous right
now you've had a distribution
that oh come on
actually let me make it disced just a a
little easier to explain let me let's
assume this was our distribution okay
and then we have another
distribution different color let's say
in
blue and this blue distribution
maybe
looks like
actually we just draw it over let's say
it looks like
this something like this so it's pretty
close but it's not super close obviously
it doesn't have enough probability Mass
have some probability Mass somewhere
else maybe it has some more probability
Mass over here to also integrate to one
okay so I can compute K between blue and
red that's we can do that if we want now
I'm going to consider a green
distribution which looks same as the
blue over here but then all the
remainder Mass sits like right here and
right
here this green distribution will
actually have the same K Divergence from
the red one as the blue has because K
just looks at for any given point how
much do your probabilities differ and
where red has overlap with green and
blue the probabilities are the same but
intuitively the the green distribution
is closer when the pr mass is not
overlapping with red at least is close
and so you would prefer if you had to
choose between green and blue for
modeling red you'd probably choose green
would be the more Natural
Choice that's what K doesn't account for
at all K doesn't care about that it
might be that it naturally cares about
it because maybe you use a gausian or
something and it's softly decays and
hence there's no other way around it
than that the kale is naturally aligned
with this but if your dist distribution
was let's say discreet at the end your K
will have no such power to do that again
it might again be that your newal
network introduces some regularization
to help you with it but in itself the
kale doesn't care green or blue equally
good models of red but we all see that
green is a closer model in terms of uh
what's going on there's something called
Earth Mover distance and the name is
essentially perfect for this think of
the probability mass as just sand effect
of we at sitting there and think about
how many little grains of sand
effectively do you have to move to get
the red distribution to become the green
distribution and over what distance and
clearly you have to move less distance
with your sand to go from red to Green
then to turn red into blue and so earth
mover distance measures that it says I
have two distributions this case
actually RNG let's say red and green um
and I'm going to measure
on average how much I have to move a
sample that comes from one distribution
to the location of a sample that comes
from the other distribution and I'm
doing this while sampling from a joint
distribution between the two so I can
make sure that if both have probability
Mass a specific location that I always
sample at the same time that location
from both distributions so it's like the
optimal correlated version of both
distributions under that optimal
correlated version how much do I have to
move my samples
around now finding out optimal
correlated distribution is a high
dimensional search space it's not clear
necessarily how to find it turns out
we're lucky there is a dual which is
easy to optimize for easier to optimize
for you can just um so this is what we
had intractable estimate but there's a
duality that says you can get the same
number out if instead you try to find a
function f that
tries to maximally
differentiate between samples from X uh
from R versus from G so you have two
distributions and your function f tries
to maximally differentiate the
samples obviously the distributions are
identical there's no way to
differentiate the expected value of
these uh featuri versions of the samples
but if the distributions are different
then you're going to find essentially a
feature Vector that highlights the
difference between the two distributions
and that will be telling you um the
distance between the two distributions
now There's a constraint on F which
essentially saying
um you cannot enlarge distances as you
process your data so if let's say it's
an image space you have pixel values and
they're Li between negative 1 and + one
you cannot all of a sudden go to 100 +
100 to try to get a large feature Vector
that makes a difference large everything
needs to stay on scale um but that's
pretty interesting because really what
this means is if you think about neural
net
land measuring how different two
distributions are comes down to just
sampling from both of them and then
training a neural
network to Output a feature Vector that
maximally pulls them apart the samples
while the network is in some sense lift
shits that is Norm constraint of what it
can do so it's a simple neural net
exercise to effectively solve for this
intractable
quantity
okay now this thing here also looks a
lot like a gan objective if you look at
it I mean there is two distributions
there is an F which is called f here if
I had called it D it would have been
almost like impossible to to not see it
um but it's kind of the same thing if I
call this thing here the data I already
have a g there I call this thing d i
call this thing D we pretty much have
our Gan objective
just formulate it slightly differently
um or a different way to get to it at
least so the washer Gan paper introduces
this as a way to effectively train Gan
models
um and of course you have to make sure
that this thing holds true what did they
do um so this is this is just the
algorithm um we sample some let going go
back to red it's a little more visible
at least to me sample some real
data we get some
noise
Z we generate some samples from
that then we we find a gradient this GW
stands for the gradient for the weight
of the ne Network FW which is trying to
differentiate samples from the real data
versus the generated
data then we update the weights so this
here is really discriminator
training and then when we're done we do
generator
training over
here
um if you structure your FW in a very
particular way be a certain kind of um
sigmoid structure effectively then you
pretty much go back to what we had now
the interesting thing is that's not what
people do cuz because the sigmoid tends
to level off your gradient so people
actually don't make that F end with a
sigmoid they just keep F more of a
open-ended um uh
output so what happens is if you train a
regular Gan discriminator shown in red
between these two distributions you get
this sharp cut off grent disappears we
of course know with the other
formulation we can already avoid this
but the W Gan also nicely void this
comes right through the gradient is
there no zero gradients um so the signal
will
propagate um the beauty is that you also
get a number actually this washer stand
thing gives you a number it tells you
something about the distance between
your generator distribution and your um
data distribution so you can actually
plot that right and you can now see a
progression during your training that
looks like a learning curve which is
much more satisfying in many ways you
know you're making progress um the the
Jensen Jensen Shannon Divergence
estimate seems to just like stay put
because we know that it's supposed to
converge that this like negative log 4
roughly I guess um and
it's I mean yeah it it doesn't give you
any signal about progression whereas
this one here um
does then the bedrooms um as good as
dcgan bedroom samples that's pretty cool
so in some sense a simpler formulation
with a learning curve that we get yet
equally good generation but it doesn't
stop there the good news kind of
continues um DC architecture but with uh
sorry without the batch Norm so the
bottom is DC
Gan the top is W
Gan we know that DC Gan can do this but
once we remove the batch from DC Gan it
fails we remove the bat Norm from wgan
it's doing just fine
um then
um
MLP um
dcan if you use MLP doesn't work W again
with MLP it's not as good as confet but
it's still pretty good so yet one more
sensitivity removed thanks to using W
Gan um the analogy is you know pretty
direct right if you look at the original
equation we had and the one at the
bottom it's the difference essentially
that you don't get that um there's no
logs introduced um but
um and there's also typically no
sigmoids introduced so there's no
sigmoid sitting inside here these have
sigmoids in them typically these will
not have that they will just be real
number outputs
um so new Divergence measure addresses
instabilities of the previous approach
much more robust architectural
choices um some progress on mode
collapse avoiding mode collapse
inability and induces the idea of L to
stabiliz can oh I forgot to mention that
on the in the training thing um in the
training the way to do the lip shits
thing is just this here they say if I
cannot um scale things up to make these
features larger I need to click my GR
that's a very naive way to keep things
lift shits in fact it's not going to
keep things LIF shits um but it's just
like a quick hack and it or already
gives good results we're going to see
much better approaches uh in the next
couple of slides that will have all the
benefits we just saw and then yes yet
some more so w g GP you directly
penalize the gradient make that more
precise so
um led by isan G rajani at the time at
Montreal
um Wisin
objective and instead of saying my
critic they call it critic the
discriminator for some reason here
instead of just discriminator but it's
the same thing it's the d d term they
say well if we want it to be lift shits
what does that mean it means that the
derivative with respect to the input the
norm of that should be um less than one
so I'm just going to force it to be as
close as possible to one so that's what
this term is I'm literally saying I'm
going to enforce lishness am I enforcing
it exactly no because I'm supposed to
enforce it everywhere not just on the
samples but at least on the samples I'm
enforcing it this makes sense the down
set is an extra back propagation you
need to do into um essentially this
objective but it's directly doing what
we're supposed to be doing interestingly
where it is done is at X hat X hat is a
random interpolation between a data
sample and a generated
sample convex interpolation so in some
sense it's trying to span the space
better than just doing it on top of the
samples themselves it might help smooth
out the optimization a bit pseudo code
um essentially same kind of pseudo code
um except that you now also have to
generate this mixture of a sample and a
real and add this to your objective
um and then separately here you optimize
the
generator some um comments here how they
could not use batch Norm because of that
LIF shits objective term it wouldn't be
compatible with that um and then they
found that bash Norm is really not
needed anymore anyway and so from this
paper onward people just stop using bash
Norm in gas because you don't need it
anymore might as well simplify it
away um
I'm going to go relatively fast here on
the architecture details the results are
even better than the w g results it's a
cleaner setup so it's a clear uh
progression very high quality samples um
became a very popular Gan model 10,000
plus citations at this point and has
been used in the ones we'll cover next
Progressive Gans style Gans and so forth
um possible negative is a slow wall
clock time you the gradient penalty
takes a bit essentially twice as long to
train your
discriminator okay so where do we go
from there Nidia came out with
essentially they started a team that was
training Gans quite extensively and was
doing very well at it um Progressive
growing of Gans instead of training it
all in one go you start with a subset of
your neural network both for
discriminator and Generator you just
work on the low resolution part
and then keep expanding from there
training larger and larger networks that
give you larger and larger higher and
higher resolution okay so it's
essentially just a progressive buildup
of your network and they had the best
face images ever seen at that
time same for other type of images just
really good quality images coming
out um bedrooms also get even better
higher resolution um you know this you
know you might even like think you're
shopping somewhere for a bed looking at
these
pictures um faces at high resolution
this is when people started saying okay
you know deep fakes in terms of face
generation you don't know if this is a
real or fake person anymore it's very
very hard to see
um so this was a big big Next Step then
there was still this thing this gradient
penalty was a bit annoying snan address
this so this out of pfn as a company in
Japan the the leading AI company in
Japan um and they said
um if what I care about is lift shits
which means some s the norm as a
propagate through my network cannot blow
up has to say put um I can maybe enforce
it in every layer don't do it for the
entire network just every layer and
maybe I can find a way to constrain the
structure of my layers so that they
automatically impose that Norm
constraint and then I don't have to do
the additional term in the
objective they said well when we look at
the lift shit's constant of a layer is a
supremum of anything I could pass into
that layer of the
gradient for that input um and then this
is well this really a Jacobian matrix
and this is the maximum singular value
of the Jacobian matrix so that's what
the lift shifts constant is computed on
that particular input um and they said
if that's what it is that's actually the
same thing as effectively looking at
um the
um the maximum effectively of in a into
a layer passing some Vector H multiply
with roughly the linearization of that
layer a and divided them by the norm of
H that number whatever H maximizes that
is going to give me the lift shift's
constant of that layer now are we're
going to search for all of them that
would be too much work um so what do you
do you just look in your batch of
samples that goes through which one you
know what they achieve in terms of norm
and you make sure it doesn't go above
one effectively you try to keep it above
one um and actually the way you can do
that by Design if you want to is by
literally dividing by the norm so if you
go through and then well actually you
divide you need to know you essentially
look at the norm and divide it back out
if you do that you're you're done so the
norm of ah you divide by that at the end
of your layer then nothing goes scaled
above
one um so
pretty pretty oops pretty simple idea no
I don't want to go back there um so
there's a long explanation in the paper
how you know getting the actual singular
value would be too much work and what
they're really doing by doing this is
doing one step of a what normally would
be an infinitely long it iteration
method to get the correct singular
value um these are their architecture
choices and they also get really nice
generations with effectively a simpler
way to set up
everything one thing that you might have
heard me mention is that sometimes we um
well often there's data sets where a
class label is available there's many
ways to to do that um this particular
paper they used the last approach but
was really you could feed it in in the
beginning you want to generate um into
your discriminator no actually yeah into
your discriminator I'm generating a
sample of this class is this a correct
sample for that class or not you can
feed it in later you can feed it in even
later um so there's many choices that
you can make where you exactly feed that
information in but the idea here is that
you can in
principle make your discriminator decide
not just whether something looks
realistic but looks realistic for a
specific class that you're supposed to
be
generating um very high quality class
conditional samples um first G to work
on full image net million image data set
and many computational benefits over the
previous
versions then the unavoidable happened
of course in a great way um actually Ian
good fellow decided to do something with
Gans again but that's not the
unavoidable part the unavoidable part is
that changing architecture to use self
attention um you know it was 2017 2018
it was the time to you know write some
easy papers in some sense where you know
whatever was done before you now do it
with self attention Transformers and it
all works a lot better it's like a
beautiful window of opportunity and this
paper nailed it for uh for Gans um
replaced you know the not all the com
but some of the conf layers with self
attention um
little tricky thing there that I had to
deal with is that self attention layers
are not lift shits as is so they changed
them up a time a little bit um some
details there they I believe they
switched to using inner products rather
than exponentiated inner products um to
help with that um but other than that
essentially self attention version of of
what was already existing and the
results were a lot
better here are some of the generations
and now you have an attention operator
you can also see see why what it's
paying attention to the discriminator to
make certain uh decisions about real or
not or certain
classification so very nice uh diverse
uh Generations even within class quite
diverse um better Inception score look
at that um and also better FID score FID
lower is better Inception higher is
better all that leads up to Big Gan 20 8
um beautiful generations of a level
Nobody seen before even higher
resolution than had been done before um
really amazing uh results this was done
by Deep Mind um great interpolations
possible um what did they do to enforce
the spectral Norm constraint uh to get
the lift shits property they said um if
I look at the weights
Matrix If I multiply with
itself
um
essentially I want it to be if it
becomes identity Matrix that means my
weight Matrix was octogonal which was
just rotating things now that's a little
restrictive I don't want to just be
rotating things but if I ensure
everything off diagonal is zero then I'm
essentially not scale and I keep the
diagonal at a good scale not scale
between 0 and one effect or between
negative 1 and plus one then I am
getting something where I'm enforcing
the
lift shits constraint while just having
a very simple additional term by the way
this
here this here is a
matrix this here 1 minus
I is another Matrix this is all ones and
then um I is only on the diagonal one so
this becomes effectively
zeros and one everywhere
else
and so what this is doing it's saying
that I'm masking out the diagonal I
don't care about the diagonal what value
it takes on but everything off diagonal
I want to bring as close as possible to
zero because I'm minimizing this
Norm so that's that's uh essentially the
way them became done some details into
how it was set up um they use um state
ofart architectures for that time you
can look at it in detail later
essentially resonant blocks um pretty
large Network much larger than anybody
had done at the time both for generator
and
discriminator um larger bats batch size
um batch Norm they they did some batch
Norm again um across the multiple GPU
course not just within your core
increasing model size wider is as
helpful as going deeper with your
network fuse the class information at
all levels not just at the beginning or
just at the end um h hinge loss um
rather than sigmoid loss and um the the
trick on from the previous slide and
then that's the regularization and this
one is essentially saying when you
sample from your gaussian you get your Z
variable you're going to generate from
sometimes you can get a you know
gaussians have a long tail you can go
pretty far out they said even though
your
gaussian could go you know anywhere
truncate truncate into this region don't
sample out of 1 plus one so you don't
get this like out of distribution things
coming into your
network I mean these are essentially
simulations that you can look at we have
a lot to cover still so I'm going to go
a little fast on this one um but
essentially I would argue that the
generations from from Big Gan are quite
comparable to a lot of generations still
that are St of V today um very good
generation
quality um from there I got morphed into
Style again uh the idea there was
instead of feeding in a z once and
generating from it you feed your Z Oops
why I do
that you feed your Z into a large nil
Network that generates an embedding
Vector W that's more meaningful you
think think of this almost like training
a PRI in our models that we covered in
previous lectures in a ve in a flow
model maybe you want to train a prior
pz I would say you can think of this as
doing the same thing it's essentially
morphing your Z from a gausian space
into a space where it's more
meaningful and then you feed it in every
layer of your generator um to generate
your image in addition you feed in some
noise and the Hope here is that the Z
that turns into W captures the
structural aspects of your image is it a
man is it a woman do they have a beard
no beard do they have hair no hair
things like that and then the noise
might be more subtle things that are
more individual variation between
individuals rather than high level
characteristics um that would go through
the Z
variable the Z variable by the way
interacts in a very limited way with uh
everything in the network if you look at
this previous slide it's just going in
here so you have this layer of
activations what's happening to it this
there's a rescaling and a offset that's
being done so you are already
normalizing by subtracting the mean
dividing by the standard deviation and
now essentially you're saying the style
of this particular image is that I don't
want to be fully normalized I want to
put myself maybe at a slightly different
scale a slightly different center
location for what I'm generating
you can do style transfer because the
style variables you can control
individually and so you can go um let's
say here is sources here are other
sources you try to bring style from B
into a um so here it's coarser here it's
middle and here it's fine so for Co um
you
know this
person comes this person here with a
coar mixing of the two if you do a much
finer mixing go all the way down here
this person roughly stays the same but
just some small details are changed they
look more like the person at the top um
so th this was the first time people had
real control over the images they're
generating Um this can be done at high
resolution um they also investigated do
you need that noise variable on the side
that introduced that slide individual
variation in some sense to each image
can't you just have the style variables
the answer is yes because otherwise it
becomes a little too templated if you
don't have that noise variable it
doesn't look as realistic it looks a
little smoothed out um if you don't have
it people don't realize that there are
these These are people at Nvidia that
like are you know there graphics people
there they want everything to be perfect
and so they see like oh my God you see
this thing over here and like on this
car here and you see this this blurry
thing over here like this looks great
but there's still like this little thing
that um I'm not happy with and if you go
at the activations in previous layer
you'll see indeed there's like a funny
thing there where clearly some things
were saturated like something saturated
to the top or to the bottom and it's
leading to these artifacts in the
generation at the end and so at the time
actually if you needed to train a new
net model to decide whether something
was AI generated or not you just need
anet that can find those little little
blur blurry things and you'd know
immediately and if you had a you know
magnifying glass you could look at it
yourself
um they made a very small
modification um essentially remember
that the Z variables could scale and
offset the mean of the Hidden
activations um they were only allowed to
do one of those two in this and now I'm
forgetting which one of the two but
either only scale or only shift not both
I forget which one they removed they
removed the one that ensure that this
artifact um doesn't show up
anymore and then you have this beautiful
uh pictures without any kind of the
little uh water bubbles
anywhere okay let's see
um okay from here I'm going to go
relatively fast over a few things then
I'm going to cover one thing still in
quite a bit of detail and then I'm going
to take a break and then Philip will
will do the last part of lecture uh
looking at some very recent
architectures okay your discriminator is
too powerful you don't like it you don't
want it to erase all the signal what do
you do you feed into your discriminator
something that comes from an encoder
rather than directly having access to
the original image and now if that
encoder has some kind of Z embedding
effectively that is generating on which
you put an information ball neck which
means you put noise on the Z so you
generate a z you put noise on it and
then the discriminator works on that Z
your discriminator will have a hard time
saturating and being too powerful
because typically in Gan training the
challenge you run into is the
discriminator wins and then everything
stops your generator is lost and so this
is a way to weaken the
discriminator
um pictorially you know discriminat
would just do this if you're not careful
historically people would put noise on
their samples hoping that it spreads
them out more and that way making it a
little harder for the discriminator but
it's kind of hacky and noise in pixel
space is not so great so really what
we're doing now is we're going to put um
discriminator is going to get an
embedding and you're going to
effectively have noise in the embedding
space z and that'll um even when there's
overlap in sample space in some sense
because the discriminator only gets Z
and there's noise on z um it will get
this kind of Bend curve and keep
propagating the
signal okay creative Gans are
essentially the same thing but now you
condition also on an image when you
generate um so pix to pix is kind of the
the common term actually largely
pioneered at Berkeley and alosia os's
group oh by the way talking about alosa
EOS anybody see the open the eyee
released today Sora the video generation
yeah a lot of people I imagine um the
the two people leading the project also
are alosa students they're working on
essentially the same thing as far as I
can tell the fusion Transformers while
they were here not have been for a year
at open a and look how much the results
had gotten better um it's pretty amazing
so imagine you're working on something
here now you spend a year at open AI how
good your results will be after that
year um if you convince the right people
at open a to you know give you the right
budget to uh to make it happen but you
know pretty amazing what one year can
can do
and and a change of Computer Resources
um
so but also this this is also coming out
of alosis group um the idea being that
instead of generating out of nothing or
on condition on a class label or
something you fit in an image and you
want to generate same image but in a
different
style for example
colorized well um you could then put a
discriminator there to say whether it's
real or fake and then train a generator
Network that is a PIX topx
generation what's the
problem well there's a lot of realistic
looking images that don't match the
original and so you need the
discriminator to not just say fake or
real but doesn't match the original also
so what do we need to do we need to
change this and the discriminator takes
in both the original
so L function for discriminator takes in
both the original
and the generated and needs to evaluate
whether they are a realistic pair so now
your real data also will need to
generate a counterpart that is in this
case grayscale and you need to feed in
both there too and discriminator learns
to understand is this a valid pair or
not um let's that's the key idea here um
one thing that might be worth
highlighting is that um in addition to
doing
that they also still use an L1
reconstruction loss on the images
because when you're training you know
the Reel that you're supposed to
generate because there's a clear reel
for that thing you condition on and L1
the idea with L1 is that L2 loss which
is a squared loss makes you fuzzy makes
you try to go in between everything L1
loss encourages you to choose a specific
value rather than try to be in between
and in fact you could take this a step
further I don't know if they did it or
not but you could just take a soft Max
output and you could probably get even
sharper results with that because that
can model multimodal outputs even better
than L1 would be able to
handle they weaken through discriminator
quite a bit to make this work these are
patch discriminators rather than a
single discriminator for the whole image
but also gives more signal for every
region you know whether it was looking
realistic or not there's a single
discriminator and then if you use a
multi- patch discriminator you get this
kind of um this case goes from
segmentation to
original
um people do this for drawings to
generate cats you just have to draw the
outline lot of things you can go check
out this was a funny one at the time um
you draw anything and it turns it into a
cat um so pretty
cool um black and white to
color um then Nvidia did something
similar for um changing the style of
people's faces go and pick to P for that
um and then AIS group did something
where you could have a dance video of
one person and then a little calibration
video of yourself and then you could
make it look like you were dancing the
way the original person was dancing so
you take the best dancer in the world um
to make it funny though um the
they also picked a ballet dancer um
which is a little more extra fun to
watch them uh incarnated as a ballet
dancer but essentially what happens is
uh there's a bit more work they did
under the hood they extracted the pose
explicitly so it's not just pick to P
it's like pick to pose and then pose and
calibration in some sense pictures of
the person you want together back onto
uh video
people do all kinds of uh creative work
with this um more Nvidia work um and you
can even you know there's you can have
the generator not generate pixels
directly but the learning to paint
essentially the generator has to do
brush Strokes so a sequence of brush
Strokes has to lead to a painting that's
indistinguishable from a realistic
painting and so you're learning a policy
effectively it's this a it becomes a um
a policy learning problem to do the
right sequence of brush Strokes to get
the painting
out okay Gans and representations um
there are two papers I'm going to cover
here second one I think you're going to
be doing as part of your your homework
um pixel values are not a good
representation we know that um we'd
rather talk about a digit like it's a
five it's tilting to the right it's a
medium thickness of the pen stroke or
pen impression and um have some codes
associated with
that so if we want
that this is regular Gan instead of
having just Z we add a code here C you
might say just adding a code is that
really going to do anything is that
going to isolate out what I want well it
could because in some you're doing
introducing a prior right and for
example if this code here is
a one hot 10-dimensional vector and
you're doing digits the most natural
thing for it to become is to encode if
it's a 0 1 2
39 so by putting the right kind of Prior
on here you can possibly enforce certain
things to
appear to help that you can then add
also a additional classifier that you
need to be able to recover the code so
the code needs to be something that can
be recovered with a classifier so now
you have two priors really whatever
distribution you choose here and
whatever architecture you choose in Q
determines what is easy to detect or not
easy to detect and hence will correlate
to what you end up putting into your
code versus what goes into your
Z now two networks why um you can just
merge it into one network that is both
doing the fake versus real
classification and the recovery of the
code I can actually do some math to show
that's actually optimizing some m
information objective between the code
and the image that's being generated um
you can look at that
later there is C1 um one of these code
variables you see that the viewpoint on
the seed is changing very Z the type of
chair is
changed very another entry of C1 um
changes the size of the chair and so we
now have control over the Viewpoint over
the size um for people we have control
over their emotions expressed over their
them wearing glasses or not wearing
glasses
um
now what happens if you do this where
you're you essentially
put this thing here this is what we
called Z and this is what we called C so
we have a big Z and then it's imet
training
1024 categories assuming here uh and we
have that as the C variable it turns out
if you train a large model that way big
Gan will produce conditional generation
effectively it figures out that there's
a thousand something classes and
generates accordingly so that's pretty
cool
um so more examples of that and also
high quality
images now to get a representation out
the big by again what it does it says
I'm also going to train an
encoder okay you might say well I'm
going to train an encoder and a decoder
in a ve you go encoder decoder it's a
loss where you need to decode back into
what you had that's not done here it's
with a different loss what's being done
is a discriminator that says are the
encoding and the original proper matches
effectively so you feed into your
discriminator a real and a encoded of
real or you feed in a sample and the Z
that originated the sample and it needs
to determine whether they are compatible
or
not um so it's another way to make your
latent code related to your image in a
meaningful
way um here are some unconditional image
Generations from in Al all looking very
good um
more um
I thought I removed those slides but I
guess they stayed
um so it's done here is you go into the
latent space z and you vary essentially
in latent space and you see that indeed
you get very similar images so the
latent space is very
meaningful
um here we look at reconstruction so
what's done is you take an
image you put it in latent space you
encode it and then you reconstruct what
you see here is interesting these are
not very precise
reconstructions but that's not
necessarily surprising because we did
not train for reconstruction we never
asked for correct reconstruction we just
asked for the semantic mean effectively
to be the same and we're getting that
the same type of dog in the
Reconstruction the details are not the
same because we're not trained to do
that but semantically clearly these
latent variables capture what we want
them to capture so very very interesting
that that's working out um more
reconstruction
and so it's very very interesting how
well this
works so this is the place where I want
to give a bit more detail
um how about an energy model if I say
the probability of a image X is e to the
power negative energy associated with X
and then I have to normalize Z is a sum
over all possible images not all the
images in my data set all the possible
images so for even for a small
resolution that's impractical you cannot
enumerate all possible images but that's
that would be a correct probabilistic
model um we saw 28x 28 by 3 images have
10 the power
16,000 um possibilities so you can't
really um do that
summation in fact Google's calculator
says it's Infinity if you compute that
number which is I thought is pretty
funny um
so in Practical to comput a summation
over infinitely many terms um but we
need that right if you don't do it if
you don't normalize by Z what are you
going to do you're going to train it for
every image Drive the energy as low as
possible and there's no counter Force
the Z is the counter force is making
sure you can't just drive everything
down and then somehow win everywhere no
when you drive everything down that
means everything is becoming likely
which means Z will be a very large
number and you divide by that and that
is the counter Force you you
need so
um this is our objective looks very
similar to things we've done before but
now the energy is being output here but
this log Z is annoying to compute
because it has a sum over infinitely
many
terms so what do we do um this is our
log z um it's a sum over all possible X
well what if we want a sample well let's
introduce a distribution Q5 multiply and
divide by it and now we have an
expectation rather than a sum over
implementing things we have an
expectation against the distribution to
compute that we can just sample from the
distribution to get an approximate uh
estimate and so that's what we're going
to do we're now going to essentially use
this distribution Q5 to sample from and
if we work it out we of course want to
maximize over Q5 to make that bound as
tight as possible when we swap the log
and the
expectation um and this what we end up
with
okay what is it saying we're trying to
find a
qf that maximizes this which means
minimizes the energy right um assuming
we're maximizing this objective and then
um there's also this entropy term so
we're trying to Miz the energy while
maintaining High entropy with our
distribution so that's that's
our objective now we add this into our
original and really what we get is a gan
objective again the energy if I had
called it D you would have already known
is a discriminator in a gan so what we
see here is that the W Gan objective is
effectively the
same as optimizing an energy based model
where we're willing to do a sample based
approximation against a distribution Q5
that we use for sampling that we
optimize at the same time and exactly
the same we now know that we maybe
should have added an entropy term in our
W Gan if we really want that energy
counterpart interpretation so you could
say hey maybe a w Gan would do even
better if we add an energy an entropy
term not always tractable to compute by
the way depends on the type of model
architecture that you use but if it's
something where you can compute it then
um maybe you want to add it um but other
than that it's the same um from w g we
know that we want to have this lift
shits constrainted so that might be an
incentive in the other direction might
say hey when we train an energy based
model you need to constrain your weights
and not be just as expressive as you
want have some constraints there so
that's not popping up here but um we
could add it and so if we added that
we'd have some some kind of combined
model of everything um that turns out to
be energy based model I'm not going to
take any questions right now um just
because we're going to be running short
soon so we effectively wgan energy based
model pretty much the same thing for a
specific approach to training the energy
based model if you're training it by
Computing your log Z by introducing a
effectively important sampling
distribution that you sample from to
compute that as
expectation um so entropy easy to
compute generally no but sometimes it
can be done it might be worth
investigating um if you're interested in
this
direction okay actually I want to
highlight one thing so John Schulman has
a write up here that I'm linking in the
slides and that write up
um there's a slightly different
formulation and you end up with the
exact original Gan effectively um with
regularizer terms so instead of ending
up with this W again you end up with
something that has the sigmoids in it um
if you set it up just slightly
differently so this here I'm going to
skip entirely it it's in the slides if
you want to check it um hasn't seen as
much activity it was kind of emerging a
couple years ago as maybe something that
would see a lot of activity but hasn't
seen as much activity yet um and I'm
going to highlight these two right now
and then we'll take a break and Philip
will do the
um the Gigan and the VQ
Gan so you can use Gans for imitation
learning you
want oh here it is this's what I wanted
to
show so if you have a classifier where
you are supposed to output something but
you're supposed to ignore a certain
property let's say you want to classify
whether somebody should get a
mortgage approved or Not by a bank the
bank wants to do within neural
network um but you say hey there are
protected properties you can now do it
based on maybe I don't know age race
other things you could say well don't
put them into the input remove them from
X but there could be proxies that's
still encoded maybe your ZIP code says a
lot about your race or your age or maybe
um well you studied says something about
it and so forth and so instead of just
removing it from the input which
probably you have to do anyway you don't
want to be removing everything to make
sure there's no proxies for it because
then you got nothing left so instead
somewhere in the middle here you Branch
out have another Network that um tries
to predict the properties that you don't
want to use so this one tries to predict
let's say race tries to predict age
maybe other things that you don't want
to be able to predict and you put a
negative sign on that one in your
training so this one try has to predict
it but your network here this part
effectively is trained to erase the
information that's needed to predict
that and so this one works as hard as it
can to still extract it but here it's
erased as much as possible while
retaining enough to satisfy at the at
the original objective or maximize the
original objective still so that's
something you can do with again that
that's pretty
cool the same thing you can do is with
uh if you let's say train something in
simulation and real you can um
do a similar loss in the Middle where
you have data from SIM and real and you
say I want to be indistinguishable
whether this embedding came from SIM or
real if my embedding is
indistinguishable from SIM or real then
everything else that happens after will
generalize between Sim and real because
I can mostly train my robot let's say in
Sim because it's just relying on an
embedding space where everything is
identical between Sim and real this can
be a lot to require I mean it's not
always realistic that that is possible
and so you might have to raise too much
information but sometimes it can
actually work quite
well okay let's see so um all right take
it away Phillip okay um so cool Peter
presented um a lot of Gan architectures
and a lot of progress that Gans have
made um but kind of what we've seen in
the last few years is that people have
this trend of trying to scale things up
to models as large as possible um and
generate really high quality um visual
results um and so Gans we've kind of
seen a little bit of falling off in this
type of era but we'll look at some of um
the improvements that Gans have also
made within the past few years towards
this direction of scaling
on um so one of the earlier works this
was around um
2021 um was styan
XL um and so one of the things one of
the properties of styan is that it
actually while it's able to Prov uh
produce really high quality
um images for for example like faces it
actually struggles a lot um for very
diverse data sets like image net and so
began architecture was actually uh stab
the art for just imet um what they're
showing here is that um styan V3 which
was a slight Improvement on styan V2 um
is not able to scale very well to image
inet whereas this improved styan XL um
they're able to make a lot of variety of
improvements to get these really high
quality image generations and actually
able to scale this to 1024 x 1024 pixel
scale um and so um they uh they have a
variety of improvements that they apply
for styan XL but we're actually not
going to uh cover them very much because
um I'll have the slides here so that you
can look at them if you're interested in
this direction after but I think um yeah
it's it it's an important one to know
but maybe not the direction that this
paper that came just last year G
um used so Giga Gan is a text to image
Gan model that is the first Gan to scale
to one billion parameters successfully
and they generate very high quality
images conditioned on text similar to a
lot of the diffusion models that we're
seeing
today and as a result of being a gan
model they inherit a lot of the nice
properties that we see from Gans um
including very fast
Generation Um and we see also the nice
disentangled prompt mixing and
interpolation properties that Peter was
showing earlier with the
stogram uh in addition they also show
really high quality upscaling results
essentially you take a low resolution
image and then from there you can
generate a much higher quality res uh a
much higher resolution
image so just really quickly um here are
some of the Giga results um these are
text conditioned image generations with
the text at the bottom and while we've
probably seen a lot of of these types of
generations models already this is a
very impressive result for again
architecture
uh and this is their
upsampling um result so it's kind of
hard to see on the screen I guess but if
you look over here here's a zoomed in
picture of what the input is um and then
over here they have the various
different um upscaling methods this one
is um a diffusion based stable diffusion
upscaler whereas these are the Gan
results and they're able to scale up um
images up to 4K resolution and you can
see that it has all these really nice
high quality
details um so how do they do this um
they have a couple of additions and
tricks that they use in order to get the
model to train stably to to this scale
and we'll go over those
now so the first um the first trick that
they do is they uh introduced this layer
called adaptive sample kernel selection
so the goal with introducing using this
layer is to increase the model capacity
size um and the approach that they take
here is to try to rather than just
scaling up the convolutional layer
Itself by increasing the channels they
actually have the model learn um the
filter to use and the way that they do
that is they instantiate a bank of n
convolutional kernels so um yeah
normally you would just have one kernel
of CN C out by by your kernel size um
but instead they instantiate n of
them um and then in order to actually
choose one they apply a soft Max so in
styan we had our style Vector W and here
they're taking that style Vector W and
then learning um weights um over the
dimension n to um yeah to select
which um which of the kernels in the
bank that it should use so this can be
seen as kind of like a differentiable
way to have the model choose which of
these kernels to
use um and then they use the same um
modulation kernel that um Stan uses on
top of
that um so the next trick that they use
is the addition of attenion layers so
here presented self attention Gan
earlier um and they found that if you
just take the style 2 architecture and
then directly apply the um self layers
it actually results in the trading
collapse of the sty and um one other
hypothesis is because that the self um
that the dot product self attention is
actually not lipshits and so they were
concerned that maybe this was resulting
in some conditioning or numerical
problems within the
model um and this paper over here the
lip shits constant of self attention
they studi this issue um and this paper
introduces or proposes a slightly
different distance metric that enables
you to make the self attention actually
lip shits and um what we can see over
here we have at the bottom left the
typical dot product
detention and you can just consider this
as a metric um that's taking the
distance some distance metric um between
these two features um and instead you
can replace this distance metric with
anything else so what they if you use
this it turns out if you use this L2
distance in instead of the dot product
distance um as well as tying the weights
of the query and the keys then this will
make the self- attention Li
shs um of course now that we're doing
text conditioning we also have to
condition the model on the actual text
that we care about and so the way that
they're doing that is they're taking a
pre-trained clip encoder
here and then taking a few additional
layers to process those clip
features um with text there's going to
be a token per um text token as well as
they have this Global token which is the
uh token that is typically used in clip
that has some Global context over the
entire
sentence and they separate out these
local tokens and the global
token so they incorporate the global
token information into the style Vector
W in the original style Gan you just
take some noise Vector Z and then pass
it through a set of layers here we're
taking um the concatenation of Z as well
as the global text token to um extract
our style Vector
W um and the way that now our W um style
and our
local uh token information is actually
incorporated into the network is used
through cross detention so the local
information is passed into the network
through these cross attention layers um
and the global information is
incorporated through the style Vector W
which is then passed in through the um
adaptive kernel layers as well as the
self attention
layers and the way that they incorporate
the style Vector into the self attention
layers is they just append it as an
extra token in the self
detention
so
um another component that they needed to
do to make this work is multiscale
Generation and so one of the ideas with
the progressive growing of Gans paper
was that um maybe it's helpful to grow
the image uh in a progressive manner
they kind of take uh uh maybe
inspiration or a similar type of idea
but instead of progressively growing
they just have the model directly output
uh or directly predict images at
different resolutions so um yeah you can
see for example out here they extract
out the feature and then directly try to
predict the image at maybe this
resolution this one is being directly
predicted at this slightly higher
resolution and so then they have these
um images at different levels um and
these are the resolutions that they're
predicting
at so in terms of the generator
architecture this is a quick summary
they um yeah and and they note that it's
important to keep some other details of
styan um and the styan Excel paper which
I had mentioned um they found that turn
you can turn off some of the additional
features of styan V2 to help improve
performance or or those are not
necessary for performance and so they
remove
those okay so now we'll quickly go over
the
discriminator the discriminator um now
has to take as we just discussed the
generator is producing images at
multiple scales and um so we want the
discriminator to be able to um leverage
these images as
well they Define this their the
generator feature extractor as f um
which takes in this full image input and
then tries to um predict uh real or fake
at the output over here um but they also
Define these
subset um feature extractors f i to J
which takes in your image at a level I
and then outputs a future map at level J
so for example um if we look at the
future map like
um uh 1 3
then that would take in this image at
this level pass it through these layers
of the network and then extract out some
features over here and so this I greater
than one indicates like a late entry
into the network and you can also have
an early exit from the
network um they also then Define a
discriminator for
each this also essentially let you
define multiple discriminators so they
can define a discriminator d j which
takes in the image at level I and then
outputs um a real or fake from the
features at level
J um so again if we were looking at like
discriminator 13 that would take in this
image and then pass through the network
over here and then try to predict fake
over
here
um and this lets them construct what
they call a multiscale input output loss
where the they actually compute all
possible combinations of input and
output scales um resulting in
like this many
losses using the traditional Gan loss as
well as what they call a matching
loss um and uh this matching aware loss
looks like this essentially one issue
that they found with training this model
is that especially early on in the
network the discriminator tends to
ignore the caption or the text
conditioning that um we're trying to
have the the generator follow and so
it's not very good at generating images
that are following the
caption so what they want to do is
encourage the discriminator to take the
text caption and classify real or fake
based on that as well so normally you
would just have um
sample a caption of hair like X and the
image X and the caption c um but then
they now they also additionally sample a
random caption from your data set C hat
and then you essentially want the
discriminator to classify um the
incorrect caption with a random image as
um a fake image as well as a fake
generated image with the incorrect
caption also as
fake
oops um so that so now we have the um
multiscale loss and then they also have
two additional losses that they um add
to get this to work so one is the clip
contrastive
loss um we haven't talked about clip but
I think we will in future lectures but
essentially they take a pre-trained clip
model which encodes text and image and
then train the mod and then the losses
how well those generated images and text
match uh match each
other and they also used this VIs Vision
AED Gan loss and this Vision AED Gan
loss was introduced in this paper
ensembling off-the-shelf models for Gan
training and um one of the features here
is that you want um they found that if
you leverage off the shelf pre-train
models you can actually help uh make the
discriminator more powerful and so
specifically they're using a clip image
encoder they extract uh which is over
here they pass in uh the generated image
and then they append some intermediary
layers that are learned uh they they
chop off some layers and then add some
new layers and then they just freeze the
pre-trained encoder and then they train
those newly added layers um to Define an
additional
discriminator um and so these are all
the tricks that they needed to do in
order to scale up to um their final
Gigan
model um the you can see kind of ones
that um applied some of the most help
one of which was the attention over
here um the addition of these matching
awar losses brought down the FID this
much and then
um the uh addition of the clip loss was
also very
helpful in comparison um in in the
modern day we have very powerful
diffusion models so this was kind of a
comparison um between how Gigan is
versus a lot of these other diffusion
based
models so um over here we have the FID
and then we can also look at inference
time in terms of how fast it is to
sample as well as um yeah and um it's
slightly unfair comparison because all
of these models are operating at 25 uh
256 pixels um but you can see that Gigan
has an FID that is comparable to a lot
of these other Fusion based ones better
than some of the earlier ones um and
slightly worse than some of the more
recent models but these are also
slightly
bigger and also in terms of just
inference speed Gigan is the fastest
where even compared to a lot of these
like distilled diffusion models which
are trying to essentially improve the uh
sampling speed for these slower
diffusion
models the final model is able to
achieve these types of really nice
capabilities which enable able you to
um um yeah so so yeah um sorry the the
final model allows you to have these
like mixing latent capabilities that we
saw with style Gan and so what they're
doing over here is they're starting with
a generation for example a cube on a
tabletop and then so they have this
thing with uh this is just the raw
generation given the text
capturing and then they're trying
to now maintain the low-level details
but then change the highlevel features
with a text prompt and so now you can
generate a new text prompt um for
example an X with a texture of Y on the
table um Y in this case will be croquet
and then you apply the style Vector to
just the second half of the network and
that lets you essentially text condition
the low just the lowle features um and
we see that here with with the cube or
the
ball or the teddy bear having these
types of um having these types of
textures um in this experiment that
they're showing over here they have
they're doing the prompt interpolation
um and again uh now it's a lot more
controllable because we can text
condition the model so for
example um we can change the caption
over here
um a modern mansion in a sunny day is
this latent a modern mansion in a sunset
is this one um and the victoriia Mansion
is here so if you remember um with sty
Gan we sample a noise Z and then pass
through the network and then with the
with Gigan they're taking the caption C
and appending that here and so what they
do here is they fix the noise Vector Z
and then they just change the caption
and that let you kind of maintain the
same random noise but then change um how
the text description changes
it um Gigan is still maybe a little bit
off from the
state-of-the-art text to image models
that we see today from diffusion here
are some of the failure modes with this
specific text prompt it's not as good as
say stable diffusion or dolly2 at these
spatial relationships um with the
skateboard um and doesn't yeah really
understand the concept of skateboard as
much as these other
approaches
really quickly we mentioned the
upsampler um and the upsampler
architecture is basically the exact same
as the generator
except we are uh there's only like a
very few modifications so the first is
now we're conditioning on an input image
that is already at some resolution so
before we had just a constant that was
fed into the bottom of the network but
instead we're replacing that with a a
unet architecture with three down
sampling blocks and six upsampling
blocks that takes in the low resolution
image they and they make some small
modifications on the uh output loss one
is the removal of the vision AED Gan
loss and instead they add this L Pips
perceptual
loss uh this L Pips perceptual loss is
very similar to the L2 loss except
instead we're going to take two
pre-trained Networks or we're going to
take one pre-train network um the vgg
network in this case and we're going to
pass both the ground truth image X into
the network and extract out these
features at these different scales we
also pass in the generated image at
these different scales and then now we
just apply an L2 loss in this future
space and then everything else is the
same as uh we had just gone through
before cool so um yeah we just talked
about the mo latest most advanced fan
that enables text to image
Generation Um but now we're going to go
into a slightly different way that we
can use Gans um specifically to help
improve quantize tokenization um and
this is actually a pretty important
topic because um the this is used as a
component in a lot of the more advanced
models of
today so if you recall back to the last
lecture we discussed the
vqv and with the
vqv the goal was to take an image and
then instead of mapping it to some
continuous space we want to map it to
some discrete space uh lower dimensional
discret
space and the procedure for VQ
vae um did this um taking the image map
it through a
network bringing it to some discrete
space
z um where we assume that that we have
some uniform prior over um this discrete
code
book and then after you train this model
um you can then create a gener of model
over this l in space where you try try
to actually learn the prior over these
discrete codes and this is what you did
in homework one um and so the main
components of the loss during the code
book learning phase is you have this
reconstruction loss to try to recover
the original image and then um this
first part of the loss tries to learn
the code book and then on the second
part of the loss is what they call the
commitment
loss in VQ
Gan the VQ Gan was introduced in this
paper called taming Transformers for
high resolution image
synthesis and what the authors noticed
is that VQ Gan has a lot of the finer
details blurred and smoothed out so um
what they're showing on the right over
here of this image of the squirrel is
this is the raw image of the squirrel
over here but after you use um
ABQ vae um you can see that a lot of
these like textures are smoothed out for
example like the stone smooth out and
the fur on the squirrel is no longer
really
visible um and what they noticed it or
what what they hypothesize is that Gans
have been very successful at achieving
crisp and realistic looking images so
maybe we can somehow leverage Gans to
improve the Reconstruction quality of of
vqv so here they have three main
Innovations to um bqan proposes three
main Innovations and yeah we'll mostly
cover the first two which is how they
actually improved the generation or or
or the tokenization in terms of actually
generating images they uh also propose
this use of a transformer whereas in the
prior works like vqv the original vqv
and vqv 2 they were using a pixel CNN so
that also was able to improve their
generation performances um but um yeah
we won't we won't go into the details of
those
results so uh the perceptual loss is the
first thing that they did they removed
the traditional L2 loss and they added
the perceptual loss we briefly talked
about the perceptual loss with the Gigan
upscaling and they also leveraged that
over here
um again it's just like a L2 loss except
now you're taking the L2 loss over
features of a learn a pre-train vgg
network
um the more interesting part of VQ is
the change of the loss function where
they additionally add again loss to
it
so uh like just training normal vqv we
have our uh vqv objective which we were
looking at earlier and they introduce
this Gan loss over here the specific Gan
that they're using for this model is
what they call is a patch Gan which was
introduced in an earlier paper and what
Patchan does
is uh okay so I guess if we look at if
we consider the normal Gan we just have
our input image over here we pass it
through the discriminator and then we
try to predict real or
fake um what patch Gan does instead is
we consider
individual image
patches so we break this image up into
non-overlapping patches and rather than
passing the entire image to the
discriminator we're now just passing all
just each individual patch into the
discriminator the intuition for why that
the authors chose to use this Gan as
opposed to the prior Gans that we were
looking at before is because we already
have a really strong reconstruction
objective from the bqv objective and
again from the initial motivation they
wanted to improve the lower level or
sorry the higher frequency details of
the reconstructed image and so the idea
here is if we have just the patch scan
kind of look at these smaller patches of
the image hopefully we can improve the
Reconstruction capability of just or or
the finer level details of just those
patches um they use this adaptive weight
um
which found which they found to slightly
improve performance um and the way that
the weight is calculated is you take
take the last layer of the generator and
then you look at the gradient between
that and the two losses and this weight
is effectively a ratio between that
gradient between these two
losses um I'll skip over the
architecture but it's um pretty standard
convolution architecture with some self
attention Block in the
middle and after you train this vuan
model you can see
that
or actually yeah we maybe have a little
bit more time so I can briefly talk
about the architecture but yeah so for
the encoder um we take in the input
image X and then pass it through um some
typical convolution down sampling blocks
this non-local block is the self
attention
block um which we can only really do at
the lower level or the lower
resolutions and then the decoder is um
the exact opposite of
that
so there's a couple of things here first
we can see that the higher frequency
details are preserved with the EQ Gan
training procedure so now again if we
look at this kind of zoomed in version
of the squirrel's
paw um you can see that vuan over here
is preserving these finer details much
more you can even see like even the
textures over here are still
preserved um if we look down here at
this mushroom you can see kind of how
that the blades of grasp over here are
still super
crisp another advantage of having a more
powerful compression algorithm um like
BQ Gan is now you can actually compress
the image even more to a smaller
dimensional lat in space so in vqv
they're taking 256x 256 images and then
bringing them down to 32x
32 and what they show in uh VQ is you
can even go press even further to 16x
16 and that's what they're showing um
over here that even if you use a higher
compression ratio you can still maintain
really high quality as well as um and
preserve a lot of the structure you can
see that the paws are slightly not as
good as um the ground truth but you're
still able to maintain high level
structure as well as these lower level
fine these finer lower level
details um over here at the bottom we
have a comparison of um how VQ Gan does
with some prior work so vqv 2 is uh yeah
just vqv to and then Dolly uh the dolly
model is in the original Dolly paper
they trained their own discret
vae um so if you look at the FID for
these models for example Dolly Dolly's
uh vae the FID is actually quite High um
and you can see that the FID is much
better for VQ Gan even though we're
compressing it a lot more so it's
already much lower and if we're using
the same resolution codes uh 32 by 32
the FID on the on the validation set is
much
lower um over here this is the
generations that they are able to get if
you use if you then take those
pre-trained latens and then train a
Transformer over it again this is what
you all did in homework one um and yeah
they're able to have much nicer
Generations or yeah much nicer
Generations than BQ
va2 uh I think yeah just in the interest
of time I'll probably skip over
questions um so now I'll just cover uh
viit VQ Gan and because of the
importance of this tokenization
procedure a lot of people were
interested in how to further improve it
and this paper proposes a couple of
those improvements um that make training
the vuan slightly easier as well as
getting better
performance so those um processes are
using the first one that they do is
rather than using convolutions which we
were looking at before they replace the
uh encoder and decoder of the vae
completely with a
Transformer um and then they also make
some modifications to the loss as well
as improve the way that the code book is
utilized so first we can consider the
loss
function um here they're calling the
loss VQ just the VQ components the loss
um and then they have these additional
compon we we maintain the L2 loss that
we always had the Reconstruction loss um
and then they kind of introduced these
additional losses over
here um the adversarial loss is the Gan
loss which we saw before but what they
did here is they used the style Gan 2
discriminator instead of the patch Gan
and they found that to actually be much
better and we'll we'll look at those
results a bit later but I think that's
pretty interesting because kind of the
original intuition for BQ Gan was to use
this patch Gan to only focus on the low
level details whereas they found that
actually if you just use the more
powerful style Gan discriminator over
the entire image uh you're able to get
much better
results uh they also introduce this
logic Lao loss over
here so the logic Le loss um looks um a
little funny but essentially what's
happening is if you look at the L2 loss
or even an L1 loss that's there's an
implicit assumption that you're kind of
modeling the the prediction distribution
to be Gan um where um the support over
the distribution can be um from negative
Infinity to positive Infinity but if you
think about that that doesn't really
make sense for images because our images
are fixed um pixel values between Z and
255 or or zero and one if we're
subtracting out normaliz it and um this
Lo so so this logic distribution was
actually proposed in the igp paper and
um they kind of take a modified ver
version of the laian distribution um by
introducing this logic over here um and
then you essentially get a PDF over zero
and one that kind of like looks like
this um and just so here's some like
kind of visualizations of what the
distribution looks like so you can
imagine and in the original paper where
they introduced this in igbt the
motivation was so that we could get a
better um we could better model how
pixels are actually distributed in the
real world and they they apply that here
as well and they find that to be very
helpful so one of the additional tricks
that they uh introduce is a factorized
code book so uh the vanilla one of the
issues that they found with the original
bqb and even uh BQ Gan is that many of
the latent codes are not actually being
used or they're being rarely
used so what they found is that if you
introduce a linear projection from the
features of your encoder into a lower
dimensional into a lower dimensional
space um you can actually greatly
improve the
um greatly improve the codebook
utilization
so what that looks like is in the
Transformer they're taking um
the features from each of the patches
and then they just linearly project them
down to a lower dimensional feature
space over here you they linearly
project them down and then they do the
codebook look up in this like lower
dimensional feature
space um and then to get back the actual
um to get back the actual features they
project back into the feature space of
the
Transformer so they found that with this
um the typical vqv was using a codebook
size of
1024 and uh with this they're able to
increase the codebook size up by a
factor of eight and still maintain
really high code
visualization uh another trick that they
employ is using L2 normalization on the
encoded latence and the codebook
latence so
um and this is very simple all they're
doing is normal taking um the features
and then normalizing them and so this
just Maps everything onto a unit
tier um and yeah they found that that
procedure helped improve um training
stability and reconstruction
quality so yeah this is some of the
results um they try to train models of a
few different
sizes they have a small model size of
base law model size and a large size um
and then the results over here they're
comparing um reconstruction quality over
these loss metrics as well as FID and
um Inception
score and with the small encoder small
decoder they're able to get extremely
high throughput in terms of um perform
uh in terms of processing
images and get even lower FID and in or
yeah get even lower FID than uh CNN
based
architecture so what they're kind of
saying here is that not only does using
the Transformer help get better
performance but you can actually get
much higher throughput and why they say
that this is potentially important is
because let's say you're trying to um
train some type of model uh like let's
say classification and you want to use
these discret l in code features um one
thing that you could potentially do is
just take your entire image data set
pass it to the network and then use
those fix L codes but what a lot of
people do in computer vision is you want
to apply a lot of data augmentations and
so that usually means you need to keep
this um latent or you need to keep your
tokenization encoder around so you can
apply augmentations to the input image
um and then get out the codes of those
augmented
images um at the bottom over here we are
looking at um we are looking at
the performance across
different uh
vqv methods so that again we have the
original Dolly discrete vae and um the
later improved VQ
Gan um and we can see that they're able
to push on that reconstruction
FID um or on that FID
metric so I think the most interesting
uh this is the ablation study that they
do in their paper and I think the one
most relevant here and the one that's
probably most interesting is the change
in architecture where um they keep
everything the same but then they're
using the patch Gan discriminator um
this is their original
model is over
here um and you can see that there's
actually a huge gap in terms of FID that
just using the style Gan discriminator
um instead of the patch gan
discriminator let you drop the FID by
half so yeah in in summary having a
better image quantitizer with respect uh
this type of approach lets you get a
better image
quantitizer and is also relatively fast
and why we potentially care about having
a better quantizer is because this means
we are have much less reduction in
information from the input and this is
important if we want to be using these
Downstream tokens for like image
understanding for
example and um this is actually quite
important because a lot of these um
generation methods that we see of today
actually leverage pre-trained uh VQ
tokens and so they'll go through this
stage one stage two approach where you
take an a huge large diverse data set
train a VQ Gan on it onto it to learn
these discrete tokens and then now use
these discrete tokens to learn
generators so one um good example of
that is party for example um they take
images and they use a pre-trained VQ
Gan um to tokenize the images and then
they essentially just train the next
token uh prediction model autoagressive
prediction model in this space uh very
similar to like the
multimodal homework question that you
all did in homework one and stable
diffusion also does something very
similar they take these uh input images
and then they first map it to a lower
dimensional zspace using a pre-trained
vqv uh where this is the encoder and
decoder of the vqv and then they apply a
generation process uh a diffusion
generation process which will cover next
lecture in that space and that enables a
lot of what is powering um the fancy
image generation models that we see
today and yeah I think that is time and
is there anything else you wanted to
cover
actually unpl
sorry